la batalla sindical continúa para una
parte de los jueguistas como aquí en
Dunn las cinco refinerías del grupo
total Energy están paradas por la falta
de acuerdo entre la cgt y la empresa a
pesar de que están cumpliendo con las
entregas mínimas
a la población repartiremos combustible
por todo el país para aliviar las
tensiones después de las peticiones del
gobierno los camiones están saliendo del
depósito de tanqueak de nuevo al final
de la cadena algunas gasolineras de la
ciudad están empezando a recibir
entregas de nuevo
tenemos gasolina eso es un alivio
pude llenar mi tanque Así que estaré
bien por un tiempo pero en el país
muchas gasolineras Siguen con escasez de
al menos un combustible algunas regiones
están viendo más afectadas que otras
como aquí en la región de París donde
las colas son cada vez más largas
habitualmente a las 8 de la mañana
estamos en el sitio aquí no es posible
hasta las 9:30 como mínimo el gobierno
prevé la vuelta a la normalidad la
próxima semana pero los expertos hablan
de 2 a 3 semanas para una recuperación
total del sector debido al tiempo
necesario para reactivar las refinerías